after locking us all down for the B part
of 3 years depriving people of their
livelihoods forcing them to inject
themselves with an experimental drug
based on reasons that Pro false taking
students out of school forcing elderly
loved ones to die alone destroying
businesses closing churches and
synagogues and so on and so on the coid
alarmists are now demanding that we just
forget about everything and move on here
is an NYU Professor on Bill Mah
explaining his reasoning
while I was on the board of my kids
school during coid I wanted a harsher
lockdown policy and in retrospect I was
wrong the the damage to kids of keeping
them out of school longer was greater
than the risk but here's the bottom line
myself our great people the CDC I'd like
to thank the governor we were all
operating with imperfect information and
we were doing our best so all it's
it's so let's but let's learn from it
let's learn from it let's learn from it
let's hold each other accountable but
let's bring a little bit of Grace and
forgiveness in that show that
was first correction they were not all
operating on imperfect information some
of them were manufacturing that false
information one of those guys was Andrew
Cuomo that that Professor pointed to he
was sitting right on the panel and Romo
intentionally cooked the book
and lied to everyone to hide his own
negligence and he was just one of many
liberals who did that but to the
professor's broader Point yes we should
of course have the charity to forgive
people from our hearts we should also
have the Prudence to deprive those
people of the power that they abused and
we should prosecute them whenever
possible for the abuses and crimes that
they committed for which they have thus
far faced zero concept consquences I'm
Michael nlls this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show a
dangerous communist leader just met with
xiin ping the leader of China that would
be Gavin Nome who wants to take Joe
Biden's job we'll get to that in just a
moment first
though the
lies that we saw during coid that we all
lived during coid that we all had to
suffer under during Co we're based on
fantasies on Preposterous little rituals
and superstitions the notion that
putting a hanky on our face would stop
the spread of a contagious Airborne
virus the the notion that's standing 6
feet away not 5T 11 in not 6t and 1 in 6
feet away that would prevent us from
giving this disease to one another the
notion that if you got the magical
experimental injection that you would
not contract coid you would not spread
coid you would not then it we found out
no actually you can contract it and you
can spread it but okay now we're being
told that it's it's a good way to
prevent you from getting extra super
duper sick or whatever it just kept
being proven wrong
and people kept taking more and more of
the drugs maybe it'll work this time
maybe it'll work that time total
Superstition and now those Libs who
spent years pedling those superstitions
have the audacity to make fun of
conservatives for being religious for
for having ordinary traditional religion
that has endured through the Millennia
Jens saki is attacking Mike Johnson the
new conservative leader of the House of
Representatives because Mike Johnson is
a Christian the Bible doesn't just
inform his worldview it is his worldview
in fact during his first speech in his
new job Johnson suggested that his
election as Speaker was an act of God
talk about a bit of a humble brag there
so what exactly has God apparently
called on Mike Johnson to do well his
views on policy are essentially what you
expect from a religious fundamentalist
they're more divisive than they are
Divine so this reminds me obviously of
when Diane Feinstein rip uh made fun of
Amy Comey Barrett and attacked her by
saying that she she feared that the
Dogma lived loudly within her the
implication being that a Catholic should
not be on the Supreme Court maybe a fake
Catholic is okay like a Joe Biden type
or a Nancy Pelosi type but an actual
practicing Catholic I should not be
permitted on the Supreme Court uh this
reminds me of when Joy bear mocked Mike
Pence I think it was for it was it was
some conservative at least for believing
that he would speak with
God and he said oh joy Bor said that's
that's crazy maybe you can pray to Jesus
but once Jesus starts talking back then
that's when you got to worry like like a
anyone who prays is a crazy person and
you see that same kind of ignorance here
with Jens saki says this this guy he
think this this man who is in a position
of civil Authority he thinks he was he
was placed there by God which is a a
very basic Christian belief St Paul
writes about this in the letter to the
Romans that the Civil Authority is given
to us by God for the execution of
justice and for our own
good if you are a Christian of any sort
you most certainly believe in Providence
the notion that that God has a plan that
unfolds throughout history ours is a
very historical religion it in fact
there's a pivot of History known as the
Incarnation and the crucifixion and the
resurrection this is like Christianity
101 folks and and what's shocking here
is not that a liberal would make fun of
Christianity they tend to be opposed to
Christianity in fact the very terms left
and right come from the French
Revolution when the Christians sat on
the right side of the National Assembly
and the revolutionaries and the atheists
and the Liberals sat on the left side of
the assembly so that's been baked in for
a long
time what's what's shocking is the
ignorance and the kind of proud glib
ignorance that she would she would mock
this guy for being a Christian when she
clearly doesn't understand the first
thing about Christianity and then
there's this final little irony here
which is that the the Liberals are so
irate at the notion of of religious
politics one they are as sup the
Liberals themselves are as superstitious
as they come they think that a man can
become a woman and they think that a
baby can magically cease to be a baby
when the mother doesn't want him but but
beyond that they they suggest that they
hate the idea of religious politics and
let me I promise you to any liberals who
might share that view who are listening
to the show right now if you think
religious conservatism is bad just wait
until you see irreligious conservatism
if you think politics informed by True
Religion broadly is is not a great thing
just you wait until you see irreligious
politics just you wait to see how bad
things can get because everybody's got
to serve somebody so if you're serving
God if you're orienting your society and
your personal life toward the good
you're going to fail it's a fallen world
but you'll be headed in the right
direction if you're just turning away
from all that and you throw morality
aside and you ignore God and you you
pursue only that which is evil and
convenient man things can get bad real
fast which is why coincidentally
providentially perhaps I'm excited to
tell you about Christian Care Ministry
right now go to medishare.com as a
dailywire listener you informed and
engaged and handsome you value your
freedom your way of life your personal
responsibility that's why you got to
check out Medishare Medishare is a
community- based approach to healthcare
that lines up with the principles you
believe in your beliefs matter and with
Medishare your Healthcare dollars will
not be used for medical procedures that
don't line up with what you believe in
Medishare is the highest rated healthare
sharing Ministry with a 30-year proven
track record members save up to 50% or
more on their monthly healthcare costs
and member satisfaction surveys show
that they like Meda share much more than
health insurance why because it works
for a limited time daily wire listeners
will receive a $150 gift card when they
join Medishare to find out more go to
medishare.com that is is medishare.com
terms and conditions apply do not wait
head on over right now get that $150
gift card when you join it is
medishare.com
micel now what exactly did Mike Johnson
say that Jens saki doesn't like Mike
Johnson said that he believes he's in
the position of speaker as a matter of
Providence he prays to God openly even
on the floor of the House of
Representatives and he did just say
something that has gone viral that is a
little theologically suspect which is uh
that he grounded his support for the
nation state of Israel his unwavering
support for the nation state of Israel
in religion in the week ahead House
Republicans will work swiftly to pass
legislation to provide Israel much
needed resources in their fight against
these barbaric terrorists we will stand
with Israel strongly there will be a
ceasefire only when Hamas ceases to be a
threat to Israel
Israel Israel and the US enjoy an
unbreakable Bond that's forged over
Decades of course of bilateral
assistance and there are lots of reasons
that we do that they are obviously our
greatest Ally in the Middle East and
clearly they are one of our most
important friends the Prime Minister
called me and I Ed those very words
myself I said I said BBE it's good over
evil it's it's um it's light over
Darkness we all see that I assure the
prime minister of our unwavering
wavering support of Israel and her
people and I assured him that our
Congress and under my leadership we will
be there until the end we will be there
until the end of this
conflict as as a as a as a Christian I
know and we believe that the Bible
teaches very clearly that we're to stand
with Israel that God will bless the
nation that blesses Israel that we're to
take peace of Jerusalem
exactly so that's the part that's a
little bit theologically eccentric the
conflation of of the people of Israel in
the Bible with the modern secular nation
state of Israel it's a view that's held
by some people and it's it's a view
grounded in a relatively novel uh
theological belief called
dispensationalism which is a distinction
between Israel and the church the
traditional Christian view that endured
for the first endured basically without
challenge for the first 1800 years or so
of of Christianity and the church is is
uh a a conflation of Israel and the
church the notion that with the New
Covenant you get u a new Israel the
notion that uh Christ is the Fulfillment
of the law that the New Testament is the
Fulfillment of the Old Testament so
that's been broadly The View uh there
are some views especially popular among
some evangelicals especially in America
that this is distinct and so then you
see a uh this as as Mike Johnson says
unbreakable support for the modern
secular nation state of Israel
okay I I understand why some people are
raising their eyebrows theologically
there the other reason putting religion
aside for a second is that listening to
the speeches of George Washington Thomas
Jefferson many great Statesmen in
American history a lot of people rightly
are skeptical of enduring unbreakable
alliances between the United States and
any other nation state period anywhere
in the world we should avoid entangling
alliances and we should have strategic
alliances but but not to say that these
are uh to totally unbreakable and
enduring for all time okay I understand
that reservation as well however Mike
Johnson is doing something really clever
here which is by going down so hard on
protecting the state of Israel one he's
saying we don't stand for terrorism we
don't we're not going to tolerate
attacks like the horrific attack that
amas Hamas carried out on Israel a few
weeks ago but he's also decoupling
aid from to Israel and to Ukraine so
what Mitch McConnell and Joe Biden and
the unip party in DC wanted to do was
they wanted to pass a massive defense
bill that would fund the war in Ukraine
and the war in Israel and potentially a
war in
Taiwan now support for Israel is still
even with the pro Hamas students running
around Harvard Yard is still quite
popular in the United States support for
Ukraine is a little more 50/50 in fact
it's actually less than 50/50 at this
point most Americans do not want to
continue supporting the war in
Ukraine and Taiwan remains to be seen
what xiin Ping
does uh if Mike Johnson can go really
hard on supporting the state of Israel
and providing War funding for the state
of Israel and saying this is going to be
the first bill we pass this is the most
important thing we
do all of a sudden now
he's ended that financial support for
the war in Ukraine which which is is not
just because we don't like ukrainians or
anything like that but it's because
people have rightly recognized that the
breakout of the first major war in
Europe since World War II threatens to
send the entire world into another
global conflict into World War III and
this is extraordinarily dangerous and
the Ukraine situation is quite
complicated as it has been for at least
um a millennium or so and the longer
this war drags on the more innocent
ukrainians are going to be killed uh the
more Russian soldiers are going to be
killed which the US views as a strategic
Victory but there's basically no chance
that Ukraine wins the war unless the
United States comes in as a direct
belligerent which would be completely
disastrous so I think it's actually a
pretty clever move here by Mike Johnson
even if some of the political and
Theological claims are uh a little
suspect to a lot of people now speaking
of this conflict in The Holy Land
speaking of Hamas the leader of Hamas
has just come out out and made a
statement that actually sends chills
down the spines of even the most
hardened political observers here's what
he
said I have said this before I say it
time
again the blood of women children and
elderly not saying that this blood is
calling for your help we are the ones
who need this
Blood we are the ones so it awakens
within us the Revolutionary
spirit so it awakens within us resol so
it awakens within us the spirit of
Challenge and pushes us to move
forward he's saying no no no don't don't
mistake my meaning here I'm not saying
that the blood of these innocent
Palestinian women and elderly and
children are calling out for revenge
against the Israelis no no no we need
their blood we Hamas we the Palestinian
Liberation Movement we need their blood
so that it can awaken in us a re
evolutionary fervor this is very very
demonic stuff U but it's not uniquely
demonic this is always the argument of
the
revolutionaries of revolutionaries going
back
centuries they say we need this kind of
Devastation we need this kind of Carnage
to to get our own blood up to awaken
within us the Revolutionary fervor to
commit acts that are obviously immoral
and consentable we need to be sent out
of our minds so that we can convince
ourselves to commit terrorism so that we
can go Target civilians for the great
Revolution that here to for our
conscience in the political order has
prevented us from achieving is the same
kind of rhetoric it's it's this is
somewhat more eloquent but it's the same
kind of rhetoric that you heard from the
Black Power movement in the 1970s from
the radical leftists like the Weather
Underground in the 1960s and70s this is
the same kind of rhetoric you hear from
antifa and BLM and all the the rest of
the Revolutionary
left and and this kind of uh rhetoric
here also helps to explain why BB
Netanyahu as the leader of the state of
Israel
has not encouraged the strength of Hamas
in Gaza but not totally discouraged it
either over his now many governments uh
you may have seen this meme going around
that Netanyahu that state of Israel was
the one propping up Hamas and that's
somewhat dishonest but there is a grain
of Truth to that which is that the
Netanyahu government and this has been
widely reported throughout Israeli
journalism and I see it as a pretty wise
political strategy in fact they decided
that the way to prevent Palestinian
statehood which the state of Israel
views as an unacceptable solution at
least Netanyahu views it as an
unacceptable solution is to split off
the West Bank from Gaza so you've got
these two Palestinian territ Tories that
are separated by the state of Israel and
if they have Unified Government then the
cause for Palestinian statehood is
relatively strong especially given all
of the international support that it
receives and including from the UN so if
the West Bank and Gaza are being run by
the Palestinian Authority which is
viewed as relatively moderate the cause
for Palestinian statehood is relatively
strong if the West Bank and Gaza are
being run by even the PLO the Palestine
Liberation Organization the cause for
Palestinian state Ood is somewhat strong
but if the West Bank is being run by the
so-called moderates of the Palestinian
political movement and Gaza is being run
by the most ghoulish demonic terrorists
you could possibly come up with in a
Hollywood cartoon then there is no cause
for Palestinian statehood if if Gaza is
being run if Gaza will elect someone
like that guy who is saying we demand
the blood of women and children and the
elderly then it's a complete non-starter
but it but it was a dangerous strategy
for Netanyahu because it does embolden
Hamas then as the leaders of Gaza and
then you see horrific terrorist attacks
like you saw on October 7th which is uh
obviously a very hot debate within
Israel right now although amid the fog
of War which which Netanyahu is now
calling an existential War a second war
for independence uh he'll probably
maintain some support but that guy I
mean that that demoniac there that you
hear calling for the blood of the
innocence that guy is the argument
against Palestinian statehood and as
long as he remains prominent in power I
don't see how anyone could really make a
counterargument now when you want to pay
attention to lighter things in your life
when you want a little levity a little
Joy you probably turn to things like
your sweet little dog and when you want
your dog to be healthy you got to check
out Ruff greens right now go to Ruff
greens.com
naturopathic doct Dennis black the
founder of Ru greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food may as well be
considered dead food since it contains
very little nutritional value let rough
greens bring your dog's food back to
life rough greens is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just need to sprinkle
rough Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too naturopathic
doctor Dennis black is so confident that
rough greens will improve your dog's
health he is offering my listeners a
free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try it get a free jump start trial
bag delivered straight to your door in
just a few business days go to Ru
greens.com or call 844
rf123 that is r ufg greens.com or call
844 ruff1 123
today remove the unpleasant Taste of
woke from your Halloween candy get
Jeremy's chocolate instead we decided
you deserve a treat for dealing with all
the woke around you that is why for
Halloween we are giving you 30 30% off
Jeremy's chocolate that means our famous
Heim with nuts and she her nutless or
30% off get yours in full size or our
sharable microaggression size perfect
for giving out to friends family and
neighbors time is running out today is
your last chance to get 30 30% off your
Jeremy's chocolate go to Jeremy
chocolate.com
today speaking of dividing and
conquering there is a new democrat in
the race against Joe Biden and it's not
the kind of Woo Woo new Agy lady Maryann
Williamson and it's not the Fairly
eccentric quasi populist Robert F
Kennedy Jr this is an ordinary Democrat
Congressman are you running for
president I am I have to I think
President Biden has done a spectacular
job for our country but it's not about
the past this is an election about the
future I will not sit still I will not
be quiet in the face of numbers that are
so clearly saying that we're going to be
facing an emergency next no
this is Congressman Phillips I don't
even know what his first name is but
he's a a fairly wealthy congressman and
most interestingly he's not Bobby
Kennedy Jr this is not a guy who's
running for president because he says
Joe Biden's gone crazy or Joe Biden
pushed the wrong policy or Joe Biden
this or Joe Biden that this is a guy who
voted with Joe
Biden 100% of the time this according to
to analyses Phillips has voted with Joe
Biden's stated public policy
positions 100% of the time this makes
him more liberal than average in the
117th Congress when predictive scoring
is used so Bobby Kennedy he differs from
the Democrats on an issue like uh
vaccines Bobby Kennedy differs from the
Democrats even on other policy issues in
that he is somewhat more moderate on
immigration somewhat more moderate
perhaps on abortion somewhat more
moderate even on energy though he at
other times he's also been extremely
environmentalist but but Kennedy is
running as a 1960s Democrat and the
party's obviously moved far to the left
since the kennedies this guy's not this
guy is just running as Joe Biden but
younger and more
competent a mainstream leftwing Democrat
running against Joe Biden's age and
Frailty that means that actual Democrats
are smelling blood in the water and
they're looking at Biden's approval
rating and they're thinking hm maybe we
won't be able to rig this thing up quite
so well to overcome the Gap in
enthusiasm that Joe Biden is going to
face so now we've got a few Democrats
and one serious Democrat running against
Biden and there's another one waiting in
the wings because governor Patrick
baitman over there from California Mr
Nome has just for some reason met with
Chinese Communist Party chairman sh Jin
ping so Nome makes a little trip to
China you know just a little jaunt
overseas and takes pictures smiling
dealing with chairman shei he says that
he's there to push for climate
cooperation uh but now because the US
and China are potentially hurdling
toward a conflict if we do end up in
World War III this is seen as
uh a little bit more
serious it's similar to when uh Ronda
santz as governor of Florida took a
Florida business sponsored trip to East
Asia and everyone knew he was only doing
that to give him some foreign policy
cred when he ran for president the same
thing applies here with Nome Nome has
been even less subtle than DeSantis was
before he declared his run for president
uh Governor baitman over here just
recently told Politico regarding the
Israel Palestine conflict
I wish I was President of the United
States and this is how Politico reports
it I wish I was President of the United
States He said
sarcastically before clarifying that he
was joking I could start doing all those
things whatever needs to get done in
Israel Palestine and I love political
carrying the water oh yes he said this
sarcastically the extremely ambitious
politician who's been raising money like
he's running for president who's been
traveling all around the country like
he's running for president who's going
to have a debate with the number two guy
who was running for the Republican
nomination for president who just
visited China to meet with the leader of
China our number one geopolitical
adversary in the entire world yeah that
guy he's just being sarcastic he's just
joking it's just a
joke he just wishes he could be
president is a joke because he'd do a
much better job than Joe Biden as a joke
as a joke this guy is effectively
running for president already now the
difference between someone like
Congressman Phillips and Governor Nome
is Congressman Phillips is just going to
run he's going to openly challenge Joe
Biden uh he doesn't have much of a shot
ever to succeed at running for president
so okay why not go all
in Nome is considered a relatively top
tier candidate for president if not this
cycle then next cycle if not next cycle
then maybe even the following cycle so
he's got more to lose here so nome's not
going to openly Pit himself against Joe
Biden he's just going to run he's just
going to effective ly run he's going to
do all the things other than declare
that candidates do when they're running
for president and he's basically going
to hope that Joe Biden slips and Falls
hate to say it I don't wish ill on the
president whatsoever especially don't
because I don't want Gavin Newsome
waiting in the wings but that Gavin
Newsome is running a
campaign that can only succeed if Joe
Biden is actually incapacitated and
unable to run for
president that's what governor baitman
does now speaking of people who remind
me of serial killers There's an actual
serial killer uh this Ohio woman was
just charged in connection to the deaths
of at least four men that she had met
for sex this according to the cops here
it could be more men her name is Rebecca
Auborn she's only 33 years old clearly
lived a little bit of a hard life if you
look at her mug shot uh She's accused of
robbing and fatally drugging victims in
January a 2 in April 1 in June according
to a joint statement from the Attorney
General of Ohio and the Columbus Police
Chief and here is what the AG said AG
said don't buy sex in Ohio it ruins
lives and could cost yours obviously
true so the woman was a hooker I guess
and these Sad Sack men were paying her
for sex and they wind up getting killed
for their trouble
which underscores a point that I've made
for some years now
against legalizing or decriminalizing
sex work against the hookup culture
against swipe right
culture it is better to sleep with
people you
know and it is even better to sleep with
people you like and it is best of all to
sleep with with your
spouse and that I guess is controversial
today that in fact that is controversial
if if if I were running for office and I
said hey I I used the nor McDonald line
I said hey sex is obviously a filthy
shameful thing that's only meant for
procreation and you should only do it
with your wife if I came out and said
that the Jens sakis of the world the the
liberal commentators the Democrat
politicians they would laugh at me they
would call me crazy they would Mo me
they would pretend that my view was
totally French that is the view that has
been held by most people in most
civilized places on Earth for all of
human
history and it's been mocked in recent
years and then even the Attorney General
of Ohio then even some of the liberal
media if they report on that story
they're going to have to admit it's true
it's the what rard Kipling called the
gods of the copy book headings the the
the knowledge that we''ve all had had
for so many years that the radicals in
the revolutionaries overthrow and they
say our ancestors our grandparents and
all the people before them they they
were just dumb idiots they didn't know
anything we we've invented the world a
new it's all different now and men can
be women and babies don't have to be
babies and all the old rules no longer
apply but they do the rules keep coming
back because it's not up to you it's up
to reality okay and the more that you
twist your political ideology away
from those sometimes inconvenient
sometimes undesired facts of reality the
more likely you will be to find yourself
a victim a victim of political chaos or
in this case a victim of a serial
killing psycho hooker speaking of famous
women Taylor Swift is now a billionaire
she's become a billionaire because of
that concert tour that she went on last
year the Aras
tour
I other than on this show when my
producers have made me do it I don't
think I've ever consciously listened to
a Taylor Swift song I'm sure I would
recognize some of them if I if they came
on the radio but I the the one that
comes to mind is is uh I'm the problem
it's me because we did it on the show
but i c i I just haven't paid attention
to Taylor Swift and yet when she
launched her tour and I came into the
office all the girls in this office were
on their computers this is I don't know
when it was right right after my show
first thing in the morning they're
refreshing Ticket Master because they've
got the American Express extra pass to
to buy the tickets early and the tickets
were a bazillion dollars and they were
they were so excited so what I have
friends of mine female friends very
serious women very normal people went
crazy for Taylor Swift paid lots of
money and inconvenience themselves to go
see the show I didn't get it but
obviously 50 million Frenchman can't be
wrong the the tour has brought Swift's
net worth to $1.1 billion according to
Bloomberg why is
it I think I'll expand on this I'll even
expound on this in in the coming days
and weeks but I I think the reason that
Taylor Swift is singularly successful
probably the most powerful woman on
earth right now is
because she's basically
normal she is pretty she's not she's not
a runway model she's pretty she sounds
pleasant she's not uh not
Mozart she's not pavati but she sounds
pleasant enough to totally inoffensive
she doesn't have a ton of tattoos she
doesn't have crazy hair she doesn't
have a million weird piercings she's
just she doesn't go Screech and scream
all that if she has political views
they're
relatively mildly stated she just she's
just normal and nice and pleasant
and for much of our nation's history
that would have made Taylor Swift
totally unexceptional no one would know
her name but at this moment which is so
absurd which is so insane which is so
divorced from reality just a little bit
of normal is refreshing and desired and
if you are that normal person you can
make a billion dollars
apparently speaking of what people want
there is a new number two candidate
in Iowa for the Republican party and
that would be Nikki Haley who in the
picture on the screen is wearing a
sweater that I own it's one of my
favorite sweaters it's that cool Ralph
Lauren flag sweater and Nikki Haley also
looks good sounds good is basically
inoffensive she doesn't fire up the base
necessarily
but she is firing up a portion of the
GOP that desires some kind of return to
Norm noral and this is really bad news
for DeSantis because disantis was the
number two guy in Iowa Trump still has a
big lead but the DeSantis campaign was
doubling down moving a lot of their
campaign staff and resources to Iowa and
so the news that Nikki Haley is now tied
with him in Iowa is not going to be
welcome why is it why is Dan santis
failing to catch fire I really like Ron
DeSantis I think he's a good guy
personally I think he was a great
Governor I think he'd make a good
president why is he not catching on
because because you know I hate to say I
told you so but it's because of what
I've observed as desantis's biggest
challenge from the beginning which is
that his candidacy was pitched as Donald
Trump without the baggage and Trump
without the baggage only works if Trump
is not in the race because if Trump is
in the race people are going to want the
original even if New Coke tastes better
than old Coke people want the OG they
want the Coca-Cola classic so for the
people who like Trump and they like the
ways in which Trump changed the GOP and
in in my view return to the GOP to
something much more traditional much
more in line with its own history but if
you kind of like
that and even if you think that Trump he
tweets too much he says crazy things
whatever you're still probably going to
be with Trump maybe some people will
spin-off but you're still you're still
probably going to stick with
Trump and if you don't like Trump then
you're going to hate Trump without the
baggage because Trump without the
baggage the the pitch at least is that
it's just a more effective version of
trump with all the same priorities and
with all the same potential achievements
maybe even more achievements in that
direction which you don't like because
you are opposed to Trump you were
opposed to the ways in which Trump
changed the Republican party so where
does that leave you the pitch of it was
Ronda santis is the best of all worlds
and I I think the guy would be
terrific but the reality on the ground
as some of us predicted and is is this
being worn out in the polls now not just
with Trump's numbers but with the other
candidates numbers is that it leaves you
without a
constituency because your natural base
is going to your Chief
opponent and the people to whom you're
trying to also appeal so you get a
little bit broader slice of the
electorate is going to go to someone who
is totally
distinct from the front runner so it
leaves you now in second place but who
knows how much longer and Nikki Haley
who many people were calling to drop out
of the race early on because they said
she doesn't have a snowballs chance in
hell she's out of touch with the current
GOP base I always thought she might have
a bit of a shot because she's offering
an alternative she's offering a distinct
view to Trump which could which could at
least have some Runway
now my favorite comment yesterday is Jun
Turner
8331 who says I'm a boomer and I never
want to see sex scenes I grew with Jen z
Oh yes in response to this survey that
showed that Zoomers are less interested
than older Generations and seeing sex in
movies that's true you're one of the
reasonable Boomers there are reasonable
Boomers reasonable gen xers reasonable
Millennials but it's a minority it's a
it's a distinct minority a Remnant if
you
will now also in Iowa also in the GOP
Primary Tim Scott is pinning his
candidacy on Iowa in fact he's come out
and said that that he is running on Iowa
or bust that's one of the reasons why
we're heading to Iowa and staying there
consistently because we realize is that
historically speaking Iowa voters they
break late in the cycle and that's great
news having an opportunity for us to
continue to share our message and to do
it uh full-time in Iowa will be very
helpful and also we have to remember
historically 2011 2015 it was Herman
Kane and Ben Carson were leading in the
de moan register poll so we are excited
about where we are we have made the
decision that it's Iowa or bust for us
and I'm looking forward to being there
Iowa or bust and so his argument is Tim
Kane was leading in 2012 so just because
Trump is leading now or DeSantis or
Haley don't forget Tim Kane not Tim Kane
he was almost the second woman president
uh Herman Kane was leading in
2012 and then what happened then Rick
sorum won and I love Rick Santorum and
it would have been great if he were
president but he wasn't he didn't he
didn't get the nomination Mitt Romney
did so if the argument is look some
other guy was leading in 2012 but then
another guy beat him and we're going to
be that guy who beat him but the guy who
beat him didn't win the the primary what
happened in 2016 Ben Carson was leading
in 2016 oh yeah and then what happened
and then Ted Cruz won Iowa and then he
lost the Republican nomination oh that's
no good okay let's expand it out a
little bit what happened in 2008 in 2008
I don't know who looked like he was
leading but then Mike Huckabee won Iowa
and then what happened then John McCain
won the
nomination what happened in 2000 that
was the last time in a a Republican
primary that the guy who got the
nomination actually won in Iowa so this
doesn't seem like a great strategy for
Tim Scott if he wants to be the nominee
but presumably Tim Scott is not running
to be the nominee the numbers just don't
bear it out but Tim Scott's a very
talented politician he's a nice guy
so it would seem to me that his strategy
right now is just stay in the race as
long as possible and a win in Iowa would
would allow him to stay in the race
longer and so then some of the the also
rans will drop out he'll be in a
stronger position then assuming he
doesn't have this breakthrough moment
when he does endorse the eventual
nominee he'll have more leverage he
could maybe get a cabinet position he
could maybe be considered as a running
mate that is what it seems he is running
for I don't that Tim Scott's a smart guy
his campaign staff I'm sure sure is
smart they must be hearing their own
argument and if their own argument is no
look we're going to be like Rick
Santorum in 2012 we're going to be like
Ted Cruz in 2016 then the argument is
we're not going to be the nominee now
speaking of people making choices like
in
elections we're going to turn our
attention to someone who refuses to make
choices that would be the
[Music]
non
now fittingly it's Tuesday so the rest
of the show continues now you do not
want to miss it become a member use code
noes KW a checkout for 2 months free on
all annual
[Music]
plans